this right over here is the graph of X
plus y is equal to one and let's say
that the region that's below that that's
below this graph but still in the first
quadrant that this is the base of a
three dimensional figure so this region
right over here is the base of the of a
three dimensional figure and what we
know about this three dimensional figure
is if we were to take cross sections
that are perpendicular to the x axis so
cross-sections I guess we could say that
are parallel to the y-axis so let's say
we were take a cross section like that
we know that this will be a semicircle
so if we take a slightly different view
of the same three-dimensional figure we
would see something like this I've kind
of laid the coordinate plane down flat
and I'm looking at it from above so this
cross section if we're looking at it at
an angle and if this if the figure were
transparent it would be this
cross-section right over here it would
be that cross-section right over here
which is which is a which is a
semicircle if we were to take this
cross-section right over here along the
y-axis that would be this cross-section
this larger this larger semicircle so
given that given what I've just told you
I encourage you to pause the video and
see if you can figure out the volume of
this of this thing that I've I could
shade it in a little bit the volume of
this thing that I've just started this
three-dimensional figure that we are
that we are attempting to visualize so
I'm assuming you've had a go at it
and one way to think about it is well
let's just think about each of these
let's let's split up the figure into a
bunch of disks into a bunch of disks if
you figure out the volume of each of
those disks if you figure out the volume
of each of those disks and sum them up
then that would be a pretty good
approximation for the volume of the
whole thing and then if you took the
limit as you get an infinite number of
disks that are infinitely thin then
you're going to get the exact volume so
let's just say let's just take the
approximating case first so let's say
that right over here
at X what is going to be what is going
to be the diameter what is going to be
the diameter of the disk at X well to
think about that we just have to re
Express X plus y is equal to 1 that's
the same thing as saying that the
function that f of X or Y is equal to f
of X is equal to 1 minus X and so the
diameter of this circle right over here
let me make it clear the diameter of
this circle is going to be this height
it's going to be the difference between
1 minus X and the x axis or between 1
minus X and x equals 0 and so this is
just going to be as a function of X the
diameter is going to be 1 minus X now if
you want to find the surface area for a
circle or if we want to find the area I
guess you could say of a circle we know
that area is PI R squared now for our
semicircle you're going to divide by 2
so what's the radius going to be so let
me zoom in a little bit so what is the
radius of one of these semicircles going
to be so the radius I could draw it like
this my best attempt to draw one of
these things so it's going to look
something like this I'm trying to draw
it at an angle so the radius what's
going to be half the diameter the
diameter is 1 minus X the radius the
radius is going to be 1 minus x over 2
right that distance is 1 minus x over 2
that distance is 1 minus x over 2 that
distance is 1 minus x over 2 so that is
1 minus x over 2 is equal to the radius
and so what would be the what would be
the area of what would be the area of
this side right over here
well if it was a full circle would be PI
R squared but it's a it's a semicircle
so it's PI R squared over 2 so let me
write this so the area is equal to PI R
squared R squared over 2 because it's a
semicircle so in terms of X I guess is
it going to say our area as a function
of X right over there
that way our areas of function of X is
going to be PI over 2 let me just write
that it's going to be PI over 2 times 1
minus x over 2 squared so it's 1 minus x
over 2 over 2 squared and so if I wanted
a volume of just this just this this
disk right over here I then multiply
that area times the depth I just
multiplied the area times this depth
here and we could call that DX or we
could call that Delta X so we could call
the depth there Delta X Delta X now
that's that's the actually me be clear
that's the area the volume the volume of
one of those shells is going to be equal
to and I'll just write this in one color
it's going to be PI over 2 times 1 minus
x over 2 squared times the depth the
area times the depth so this is volume
of one of these half disks half disks so
the volume of the whole thing we can
approximate is the sum of these or we
could take the limit is our Delta X's
get much much much much smaller and we
have an infinite number of these things
which is essentially if we're taking
that limit we're going to take the
definite integral so we could take the
definite integral so the volume that we
care about the volume of this figure is
going to be equal to the definite
integral from x equals 0 to x equals 1
that's where we intersect the x-axis its
equals 0 to x equals 1 of we're
integrating an infinite number of these
things that are that are infinitely I
guess thin so it's going to be let me
write it it's going to be PI over 2
times I'll just write it what's 1 minus
x squared let me just expand it out for
fun right over here so that's going to
be that's the same thing as X minus 1
squared so it's going to be x squared
minus 2x plus 1
and then 2 squared is 4 / / 4 and
instead of Delta X I'm going to write DX
now I'm going to write DX because I'm
taking the limit as these become
infinitely small and I have an infinite
none I'm summing an infinite number of
them so the volume is just going to be
we just have to evaluate this definite
integral and if you feel so inspired but
if you feel inspired at the moment feel
free to pause and try to solve and try
to evaluate this definite integral so
let's just take some of these constants
out so let's take PI over 8 out so our
volume our volume is going to be equal
to PI over 8 times the definite integral
from 0 to 1 of x squared minus 2x plus 1
DX DX which is equal to PI over 8 PI
over 8 and so the antiderivative of this
is X to the third over 3 - x squared
plus X and we're going to evaluate that
at 0 and 1 0 and 1 and so this is going
to be equal to PI over 8 when you
evaluate it at 1 you get 1/3 minus 1
plus 1 so it's going to be one-third and
when you evaluate at 0 you get at 0
minus 0 plus 0 so it's going to be minus
0 so it's just PI over 8 times 1/3 which
is equal to PI over 24 and we are done